what's up everybody got a 2015 lariat
right now
um and i am going to show you how to go
from the old style key to the new style
key
all right so let's go through
i could not find any videos of someone
that had my particular car
trying to upgrade keys i mean upgrading
keys is not really a common thing
but i'm going to show you how i did it
because these keys
this bottom thing always breaks um
it's just not a great key um
and this is just a lot more solid
obviously it's missing a little
extra key thing right here but let me
show you how i did it all right so
it is a process of going from your car
completely off to your car going into
accessory mode
while you have your key in its little
slot
now i think mine's a 2015 i think on the
later models
it's in one of these cup holders so
check under here
i think it's like right here anyway so
for a 2015
with keyless entry and keyless start
i have my two original keys
right here okay and
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
take your first key
with the buttons up and place it
in there like so now your car is
completely off i'm just doing this
because i have ac and i'm not actually
doing it
so car is completely off you press
the car so that it turns into accessory
mode on
you count five seconds five seconds
turn it off now take this key out
put it over here put the other one in
there
keys up turn it accessory on
five mississippi accessory off
now this key out and take your new key
without the the actual key this part
just press a button
buttons up in there
and go ahead and press accessory on
now at this point my truck
uh blinked its hazards
and uh it said key programmed
uh i tried this about 10 times
unsuccessfully
and then the 11th time i was able to do
it i held this down
a little bit and i pressed the button
and that's when it worked
now i tried it with the ford symbol
up and it didn't work when i tried it
with the buttons up
it worked maybe coincidence but um i'm
telling you my recipe
for this to be a successful um key
programming
so i'm going to go over it one more time
keep
cars completely off you're going
one key buttons up in the slot
cars off hit this to turn accessory mode
on
five seconds turn it off change the key
again on one two three four five
mississippi
off take it out put those to the side
now you take your new key put it in
there
hold it down on
and then at that point you should see
some
unusual activity either hazards flashing
it says right there
uh key programmed and then this will
work
so you can see
um and then obviously the car is on so i
can't show you it starting but
all the buttons work it all works i got
this on ebay
for like 40 bucks i could put a link
below to the guy
that sold them to me i was a little
concerned but i now am going to get a
second one of these
so that i have my primary and my
secondary
are these new type and then these i can
have just in case
anything goes wrong but hope that helps
and see if you have any questions i'll
hopefully answer them
but that was my experience good luck